[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey one more day till Christmas one more
day till Christmas
party Christmas yeah holiday party
holiday party welcome back everybody to
the break room the daily nerdy news show
that talks about everything you need to
know and today we're talking James Gunn
and what's going down at DC films okay
uh we'll also be talking a little bit uh
rensslayer in the TVA Wookies old as
hell confirmed
um uh with me today to discuss those
topics some more we've got Brandon
Barrick oh hello we've got Jessica
Clemens oh hello and we've got Tommy
Bechtel
oh going deep tell me uh no uh chat
Redemption today we appreciate everybody
in the chat and everybody sending in
super chats if you send in um some super
chats we'll be sure to read all those
super chats by the end of the show uh
filtering out the truly disgusting ones
yeah
um but the only mildly disgusting ones
we'll get to those
uh so we're jumping right into our main
discussion today big big news coming out
of DC films uh reports are that the
upcoming one woman three uh has been
canceled uh toe tagged as they say In
The Biz oh is that what they say
director Patty Jenkins who had directed
the first two films
um had created a treatment which
treatment is like a stage and
screenwriting that is before the full
script yeah but it's like maybe a
10-page outline of what the movies
yeah you've moved past just the pitch
phase of the story and you've gone into
it's basically I think scene by CM uh
two or three sentences on each scene
yeah the ACT structure everything like
that she turned that in uh to Warner
Brothers DC films and the current DC
films heads James Gunn and Peter Safran
uh did not like it now there's been some
like very late breaking news about this
that we'll get to in a moment
um but supposedly they said no we don't
want to make this movie movies kind of
canceled weird timing just yesterday or
Tuesday Tuesday Gal Gadot had tweeted
out I love so there it is a few years
ago his announcer is going to play
Wonder Woman I'm so grateful for the
opportunity to play such an incredible
icon character and more than anything
I'm grateful for you the fans can't wait
to share her next chapter with you the
chapter is going to be an epilogue
because James got tried to do a dream
shot her yesterday God damn now again
the this this report came out in The
Hollywood Reporter uh this was not a
press release from Warner Brothers or
Disney or I'm sorry or DC or James Gunn
or anybody I mean Disney might have put
out this press release yeah wait isn't
it weird like the rock also put out a
tweet that was like Black Adam is
officially profitable had to wait to say
I don't know are we getting into that
list no no I was like so did uh what's
his name uh Henry Cavill do you think
they were like all their all their reps
got together were like tweet out how
happy you are to be a part of this yeah
and so there's an interesting
conversation what we're excited to talk
about right is like it feels like right
now the future of DC is getting decided
right and and we're gonna kind of
explain everything we know so far and
kind of using that we are going to
predict what is going to come in the
future okay so what we know so far
there's rumor uh that came out yesterday
that Wonder Woman 3 was scrapped the
treatment that movie's not going to get
made probably also meaning gal gadot's
time as Wonder Woman is over potentially
I mean they could bring her back as the
character which is like whatever story
they had put together for Wonder Woman
three they didn't like and that was
always weird because
over the year we've had kind of stories
about this this movie and like one of
them was like uh Gal Gadot and Patty
Jenkins doing an interview with the
reporter from like a hotel room where
they're like yeah we're huddled together
we're putting this movie together even
though no one from DC had announced it
it kind of just been like soft assumed
after the second movie that it would be
happening you know and I think that's
really interesting because you know the
second movie obviously was released
directly to HBO Max during the pandemic
so there was no real quantifiable way to
judge its you know dollar signs reaction
critically received pretty poorly fan
wise received very poorly especially
after how good and well received and
critically successful the first one was
so I was kind of surprised how bullish
they were on getting a Wonder Woman 3
announced and out just based on the fact
that like Wonder Woman 84 was generally
kind of panned by everyone including my
mother who was the most generous movie
critic of all time was like I didn't
like that one as much as the other one
which is for her basically saying the f
word to Patty James wow and I think oh
boy I'm sure there are some Defenders of
Wonder Woman 1984 but I think like that
first trailer I'll defend that the
trailer was sick oh yeah
um yeah I think almost everybody was
disappointed by that movie we wanted
more again based on the success yeah the
quality of the first film and it's a I
think Gal Gadot plays a great wonderful
I think she's really good in that role
she's like Amazonian I I you're gonna
think I contradict myself when you watch
Roku because I take a shot at her acting
in other movies but I think as Wonder
Woman she is really strong she's really
embraced the role one thing you can say
about the the the Snyder verse phase of
DC films is like lead actors that really
Embrace that character Jason Momoa loves
playing Aquaman we're going to come back
to that Henry Cavill really loves
playing Superman we're going to come
back to that uh and definitely Gal Gadot
really embraced being Wonder Woman Ben
Affleck was there to be Batman and Ezra
Miller loves being on the run so uh yes
okay well hey sorry guys it's Christmas
uh but so the the report was the movie
was removed from the Slate so it doesn't
mean that like they gave some notes like
hey go back to the drawing board or
anything like that instead they not only
just didn't like the treatment they were
like nope uh now it has since come out
in deadline uh they are currently
reporting uh according to those in the
know it was Patty Jenkins the director
and the person who created this
treatment who walked away after
receiving notes on the treatment she
submitted to the studio apparently her
threequel pitch had character Arc
problems which rivaled that of Wonder
Woman 1984.
well that's wild because that doesn't
sound like it comes from Patty Jenkins
camp at all this actually makes Petty
Jenkins sound even worse yeah well the
thing that's hard is like Wonder Woman
84 had the problem is there was too many
hands in the pot and I though what hurts
about this is like Patty's like please I
don't want it that wasn't what I wrote
1984 is not what I wrote please let me
try to like win you over with this but
it's like well it's already been done
and it's now in the franchise so they
also took Wonder Woman which was a
successful film was well received and
was at the time the most successful of
like this kind of Snyder verse movie
single shot movies that was happening in
in a in a situation where things felt
like they were in free fall they then
were like oh you got to put Wonder Woman
at the end of uh Batman vs Superman and
then we're immediately doing Justice
League and that totally derailed
whatever arc Arc they were doing for
Wonder Woman and then they went back to
1984 and had to kind of like make it all
work so this whole thing got messed up
after the first movie I think this is
really interesting for Patty Jenkins too
because apparently her Rogue Squadron
film is also like not happening or is at
the very end of priorities for like the
Star Wars Universe right now it's like I
kind of feel bad for Pat and Jenkins
it's like let her do one of these
projects and hey it should go without
saying here
um Patty Jenkins is like box office was
one of the all-time most successful
female directors right and like Wonder
Woman was you know right there with
Captain Marvel were like two of the most
successful successful female lad not
only super movies but movies period of
all time yes right like and that is an
incredible accomplishment she's clearly
a very talented director of any gender
um and so like it is weird and it's a
bummer that she's had two huge projects
yeah kind of get canceled trash bagged
uh back back to back chatted you mean
I'm sorry Brandon well just to say and
to no fault of her own really if it is
Studio intervention that's creating all
these problems or like you have to have
this this and this in your movie uh when
your original pitch was probably
completely different and every movie
that got pushed to streaming during the
pandemic yeah Black Widow we can name
half dozen none of them were done
Justice by that price right you know and
and I think you know it's easy to say as
you know sitting here as a straight
white male but it feels like the timing
is always tough with these because we
know it's very rare that they can say
Wonder Woman three is in its current
Incarnation gone but we have another
female driven project that's coming in
its place Batwoman or Batgirl is
canceled but we have this other thing
coming it's always just the kind of the
crater left and feel free to tell me if
I'm full of [ __ ] on any of this uh sorry
314 please don't demonetize uh uh the
crater that's left of this project being
gone is not filled by anything that like
makes you hopeful for more you know
non-straight white male lead voices for
these movies so it's like yeah they take
away Wonder Woman and they're kind of
like it's gone there's nothing that
fills in the Gap so something probably
will come along Patty Jenkins is
certainly going to direct more big
movies I don't think we're going to be
losing sight of her anytime soon I'm
hoping for an imagine sequel uh and but
I think like you know right out it just
kind of stings a little bit right it
just kind of is cut them off it doesn't
it's they cut them off yeah stop them
stop them
what I said I think with Italian fly
ninja uh kind of said this in their
Super Chat and we'll go over the super
chats later but I it it does seem like I
wouldn't mind if James Gunn does like
another Wonder Woman and we restore it
and we start we have to start fresh you
guys eventually like we have star fresh
everything has to start fresh at some
time even after blade Marvel was like
you know what let's start over let's
let's do this let's do this design yeah
Robert Downey Jr out of jail that's what
they said they said let's let's go to
prison Let's Go to Prison wait Mel
Gibson's putting him in the City
detective and Jessica that's a great
point this is a good moment to Pivot to
like okay so we know what's not
happening and that's a little bit of a
bummer great so what is happening and
just real quick we're gonna operate
under two assumptions right and those
two foundational assumptions are Warner
Brothers needs money yes obviously all
companies all Studios need money
capitalism they especially need money
right now there's a giant debt financed
uh corporate uh uh combination going on
here between water and Discovery they're
cash strapped HBO Max subscriber numbers
are not where they want them to be the
uh theatrical film business has not
bounced back to pre-pandemic numbers so
they need money hard okay two James Gunn
once and Peter saffron to a lesser
extent they want to put their stamp on
DC right they don't want to be saddled
by films and other people I should add
this treatment that Patty Jenkins turned
in was co-written by Jeff Johns previous
head of DC films right previous yes
previous right and so they're like okay
cool we don't want to and of course this
movie wouldn't have even been made for
another two years deep into the the Run
of gun and saffron right and so like
they're like yeah we want to make our
movies not somebody else's movies also
do did those to Patty Jenkins and the
Jeff Johnson and Jeff Johnson they know
they don't really know what James and
Peter have in plan right so it's like
here's my script and it's like okay well
it truly just doesn't align with what
we're doing that's right and like to go
along with that literally the the the
same Hollywood Reporter article said
that uh Peter saffron and James Gunn
have literally been like in a mountain
cabin in Aspen so last week coming up
with their DC Bible that then next week
they're going to present to um uh super
villain David
we love making it he is the last name
kind of a villain the head of uh Warner
Discovery as like their 10-year plan for
DC films kind of their new Bible so like
while they're making this she turns in
it's like there's no way those two
things were gonna happen right that
would be like hey I know Kevin feige in
the Marvel team were working on
something I was working on something
completely independent I hope this fits
well probably not I hope there's a lot
of stuff that clearly we don't know
because I don't want to demonize like
Patty Jenkins are seeing her script and
being like no I don't want to edit it
because I am like oh I firmly understand
how you feel especially after 84 and
everyone working on it you're like
here's my new stuff it doesn't involve
it before and they're like well we have
to acknowledge it so you have to
acknowledge it yeah but yeah there's
probably a lot of stuff we don't know
but these things are very hot it's hot
tea yeah and and the story is like like
we said like developing like 10 minutes
before you went on the air we got the
latest news so uh James Gunn today and
this article came out yesterday uh games
got today tweeted
um there it is
a longer thread but like the gist of
this is kind of the keynet graph he said
some of that stuff was true some of that
stuff was false and some of that stuff
we don't know if it's true or false yet
I like that right damn tomorrow Jam
yesterday but never ever jammed today
um so basically you know he's uh and
this is this is what happens in
Hollywood right like different camps are
like well my side of this story is this
my side of the story is that and the
truth is probably somewhere in between
also like they haven't even presented
their plan to their mother right so like
I like to imagine they were up in the
cabin today they got their printed
edition of The Hollywood Reporter over
morning you know they just killed a buck
yeah they're dressing it down
uh Peter and James is feel feel dressing
the buck and they're reading it and
they're like no we have to get to Wi-Fi
so we can tweet they spit some they spit
some elk blood out there oh my God yeah
they seem like the kind of uh uh blood
hungry
but so the other part of his tweets that
I think are most intriguing and this can
be the fun part of where we can
extrapolate what this means going
forward for DC films right he said the
one thing I could say is that we can't
make everybody happy all the time we can
all agree on that and that everything we
do is done in the service of the story
and in the service of the DC characters
we know you cherish and we have
cherished our whole lives there it is
um so that's great we're giving these
characters and the stories the time and
the attention they deserve okay well
that's really nice
um right I think we hope that good job
we hope that's true we cherish those
characters we do want to see them well
served so again a quick
um overview of the landscape of DC films
uh the flash Aquaman 2 Shazam 2 Fury of
the Gods those movies are basically done
they're coming out they're coming out in
the next 12 months uh Shazam Fury the
gods I think is May uh flash maybe this
summer it's July 16th June thank you and
uh I think I messed up the the Blue
Beetle blue beetles also done and coming
out thank you and in theaters right
because
Shane is believing
says everything's good everything's got
to be theaters and then Aquaman is like
the final slated in production anything
DC movie that's coming out December
almost exactly a year from now so sorry
please to me
the way the only way you get people to
go to theaters to see these movies
unless they are direct fans of the
property is two ways one you guarantee
that there is some connection to the
future of DCU with it or you presented
as this is the conclusion of this
somehow you edit together whether you
have to go Edward Scissorhands two or
through the movies you make Aquaman to
the conclusion right because otherwise
how do you get people to go see these
movies that are essentially Standalone
films that have no when you're pitching
it as a connected Universe now if it was
just a separate Aquaman movie like the
Batman the Aquaman then yeah you'd get
me out and I'd go see it but like
Aquaman 2 is ostensibly a worthless
sequel now because if there's a new I'm
not saying it's worthless but it's I'm
saying oh you could look at it from the
lens that it is and it doesn't matter
and Warner and DC is certainly hoping
that a these movies are great and again
the rumor is The Flash movie is
incredible
um and in the other movies we don't know
we haven't heard as much but um that
these will make a ton of money even if
there's no hope for sequels afterwards
even if they can't put a post-credit
scene that teases more characters or
something but I think that's where you
could just say like the conclusion of
this generation of DC films is Aquaman 2
or whatever and it's like and then
much like comic books have I mean
sometimes very maligned rebirths and new
52s and whatever it's like you just make
new new DCU I would like that but
wouldn't you have to take out the cameos
yes so we know that some cameos by both
Jason Momoa and Henry Cavill were shot
for the flash right they're gonna be we
kind of are in this weird period we're
in this post Snyder but continued Snyder
versus yeah right right I think their
drive to put out this Flash movie
despite all the you know off-screen
Shenanigans uh terribly terribly
software Shenanigans again illegal
activity but it sounds like from what
we've heard too like The Flash movie is
there like Multiverse explainer certain
way home once they once they put that
out then all of these things can make
sense but I also think DC is fine with
these things not making sense right
they're pushing forward Matt Reeves
Batman and they might also make another
Batman and I'll have Batman animated
series and Batman audio Series
yeah I love the Batman
the audio series is a banger that's
right and and one thing we know is that
they're not going to touch the Matt
Reeves Robert Pattinson Batman that
sequel's getting made they're not
touching it they're letting him do his
thing the Todd Phillips Joker sequel not
touching it letting them do their thing
um so here's here's what I want to say
going forward let's assume again Warner
Brothers likes making money but uh James
Gunn and Peter saffron don't want to
make movies that are somebody else's
deal they want to make movies that are
their deal which makes sense you want to
be they're going to be held accountable
in a couple years when it's time to
continue their contract or fire them you
know they're going to look at the movies
that were made and judge them based on
that and you don't want to be judged on
other people's work you want to be
judging your own work sure um so let's
assume that after these this next year
of movie trees that are already in the
can and slated to come out we will not
see Henry Cavill Superman again we will
not see uh Ezra Miller as the flash we
will not see probably uh Zachary Levy as
uh is it Levi Libby
Levi thank you we won't see that dude as
Shazam and we won't see Jason Momoa as
Aquaman okay now
we again we've yet to hear about what's
the first movie that's going to be green
lit that will be from Gunn and saffron
um
so
do we think there is any chance that any
of those characters or those franchises
could be rebooted
by a gun and saffron
the thing is
I want them to do that I want them to do
that with Wonder Woman I want them to do
that with Superman I would love them to
do with the Justice League entirely
because I want the Justice I I mean we
can get rid of the Justice League all
together but I love the Justice League
and I want to see them done again and I
would love to see them done a little bit
better
um so I want that but I also I'm holding
on to Shazam for now
especially because they already have the
sequel
yeah the thing is if the sequel comes
out they can just pick okay now it's
done we did a sequel like we did it yeah
and I you know it would be insane to say
that Warner Brothers will never make a
Superman movie again he's the number one
or two most famous hero in the world
right they're gonna go back to it
eventually I mean we saw how long even
Marvel eventually had to do whatever
they could to get Spider-Man because
like these iconic characters you have to
have them at some point and we deserve
another uh Superman and like I want to
see the black Superman movie eventually
get made that they keep teasing for so
long like yeah like let's they will
reboot and you have to think right again
superhero movies cost so much to make
and these studios are kind of built on
the backbone of these big franchises
they need to be able to make a billion
dollars it's gonna be tough to make a DC
movie that can make a billion dollars
that doesn't have Batman doesn't have
Superman doesn't have Wonder Woman
doesn't have Aquaman right like we're
gonna talk about it there's this rumor
Jason Momo is going to Pivot to playing
Lobo which is badass and we love the
Lobo character do we think the a lobo
movie can make as much money as an
Aquaman movie
um no I don't know I don't know are we
talking about Aquaman three
maybe yes it almost certainly can't make
as much money as like a Batman or a
Superman I say they make a lobo Aquaman
movie team up and have Momoa play both
parts
style the reason I also say please
Hercules
is because this will be a lobo trailer
by James Gunn uh it will be under James
Gunn right and we love James Gunn's
trailers and we love James Gunn's
content and I think that could
potentially get a lot of people more
than an Aquaman three or two could
because it's like we've seen that
trailer and it is I mean empty were
talking about it you know how Zack
Snyder has his like CGI it's kind of
like Sucker Punch like everything is
Sucker Punch to the movie
um it kind of felt like it was like oh
it's all dark tones it's like it's all
right I guess but if we saw Lobo James
Gunn like it would be very fun trailer I
think it would be very salsa absolutely
and I think like it was pointed out in
this article that like what made James
Gunn's name is he took characters lesser
known Marvel characters right nobody had
any any of the Guardians of the Galaxy
in their top 10 most famous most popular
whatever Comic characters and he made
Guardians huge franchise movies now
there's a Groot and a Rocket Raccoon
walking around Disneyland and there's
people who got you know Gamora t-shirts
on right and left things like that right
same way Suicide Squad with like polka
dot man yeah it was like no one knew who
that character was the calendar man you
know you know he's a quirky director he
loves Misfits and anti-heroes and
Weirdos right I don't think anybody's
describing Superman as any of those
terms right right that's true that is
true so like yeah what could he do with
a character like Lobo what could he do
with a character like dead man right
like some of these uh lesser-known weird
characters even amongst the Green
Lantern Corps there's a lot of weirdos
and different kind of characters in
there but you know whatever his plan is
and needs to include some of these huge
huge it's got to and I think he has to
bring in filmmakers that that are good
at handling these kind of Monolithic
Heroes that are like huge Superman you
can't really mess with the character too
much right like you saw even when they
made him brooding it was like people
didn't like it they wanted Christopher
Reeve Superman so you got to bring in
someone that can kind of handle that
type of thing and then let James Gunn
you know he can oversee the whole world
and like let him make a lobo movie like
you said or let him make a Dead Man
movie or let him make you know a zantana
you know Vegas Street you know shrimp is
it not strip he's very description
uh no uh yeah you know what I'm saying
no I think there's a Swamp Thing
that's a great Point Tommy because like
we know James Gunn can't make all these
DC movies if they're going to want to
put out two three four movies a year
obviously he can't make that many so
like who's he gonna get on board who's
the first signing who's the first I say
he coaches the Russo Brothers I say he
steals them from Marvel and gives them
the Justice Jessica's got knives I say
go off go off go off get Michael B
Jordan yeah give him the keys to a big
DC franchise they give them a direct or
even if oh my I just want even if it's a
series even if it's like Peacemaker give
him one episode give them one episode
action wise fighting wise I think he'd
do really good choreography I mean they
might need to take some risks right
Marvel has grouped up a lot of the big
directors Star Wars got some people on
board right like they're gonna have to
reach out to somebody Greta Gerwig fresh
off of Barbie put her right onto a DC
film here we go let's go uh what
happened to the table sheet uh we had an
idea what happened was Victoria just
ripped apart I've been trying you
accidentally ripped some pretty hateful
speech into this yeah
you know we're looking forward to I
think the next week two weeks is going
to have a ton more news about this right
we'll find out what happens in this
meeting between Gunn and saffron and
David zazlov we'll find out like maybe
some some stuff will come out maybe
they'll make an official announcement
about what their Bible says about the
future DC we're going to hear about
what's that first movie that green light
they got to start working on it now they
only have
move of months and then they got nothing
after that so they gotta have something
in the in the work I really
oh we're going to take Comic-Con this
year because I feel like DC is going to
have a panel in San Diego it's going to
be like that panel where they first
started doing the yeah San Diego they
first started doing the Marvel timeline
Graphics where they're like and this is
going to be James guys coming out and
just being like it's not gonna be sick
if like feige James Gunn yeah gets up
there in Hall h yeah and he's walking
out big movie stars he's walking out big
directors yes um I don't think I can be
there in public
uh we will be at San Diego Comic
Comic-Con and hey if you have another
comment
that you that you're working on
they're part of that you're an organ
izer of let us know we want to get out
there we had an awesome time at La Comic
Con all four of us air Voss Jay
Washington we were all at La Comic-Con
last weekend and had an incredible time
a ton of people showed up for a panel we
were walking the floor or if you just
have a live theater venue that you want
us to come to you know what we're all
trained professionals out here you want
me to do five minutes of stand up I
can't do it I can only do an hour I got
a chappella I gotta be smoking
cigarettes and I need an hour to ramp
and save it we do a traveling production
of noise as often it's quite quite
impressive Upstairs Downstairs okay
um real quick uh that that's things that
are in the future that we're looking
forward to you know what's in the
immediate future we're looking forward
to tomorrow on this show we are having
our annual holiday party our first
annual holiday party annual holiday
they won't let us do it more than once
again
but we'll be we'll be celebrating we'll
be dressed up this place is gonna be
crazy decorated and uh bartender Tommy
is going to be serving some specialty
cocktails brought to you by our good
friends at iconic cocktails the the
focus on this camera will be great but
um I'm actually wearing one of their
shirts yes it's one of their uh Cactus
Wren uh recipe but um they make these
awesome uh super high quality cocktail
mixers and they include recipes you just
put in your favorite booze and and uh
you get these really great delicious
cocktails we're gonna be making it we
actually have two signature drinks we
developed in collaboration with iconic
cocktails yes the quantum Manhattan that
is a uh a Manhattan made with uh their
cranberry thyme uh mixer uh in honor of
Ant-Man the lost quantumania and then uh
we're doing a uh nowhere to go mocktail
non-alcoholic cocktail made with their
bitter orange tonic uh and iced tea and
I have promised personally to only
marginally sample the drinks before the
show starts well I'm not driving
tomorrow so you can make me a hefty pool
oh my god well and what we've uh it's
office policy done some previous
drinking excursions that we just can't
pre-party but if you tune in tomorrow
you know about minute 48 yeah 52 that's
right this might be getting pretty lit
that's when these iconic cocktails are
really going to kick out that's where
not to quote Natalie Cole but you start
hearing my Grown-Up Christmas List
what a an obscure Natalie Cole quote
Tommy I don't even know that one Google
it guys Google it it's a great song
Do You Remember Me
sat upon your knee oh I like that okay
but hey we want to thank our friends at
iconic cocktails for helping us put this
party together and for sending me this
uh shirt uh you should order their stuff
they make delicious mixers they're great
gifts it's a good time of year to be
sending your friends uh some fancy
cocktail gifts uh you get 20 off your
order oh use our code new rock stars at
iconic cocktail.com and you should visit
iconic cocktail.com for a recipe they've
got a ton of awesome drink recipes on
there a big catalog of them uh and uh
you'll be supporting our show before we
move on Zach I just want to say I
believe you may have mentioned it but a
reminder you do have the recipes for the
drinks we are making are in the
description for this video so you can
drink along with us yeah yeah and you
know I'm stealing one of these for the
for the road when I go back to Rochester
to warm those cold Rochester nights but
I'll be having
delicious uh well it's not just DC news
today folks let's get into some other
headlines
oh my gosh uh I forgot to put this one
in the script but Michelle yo has been
cast in the upcoming Wicked movie and
she just did an interview where she's
like I mean I know Wicked is a movie but
she's like I can't do live theater I
have too much stage fright she was like
but evidently
I don't know I don't know actually she
does remember she sings uh briefly I
think and everything everywhere all at
once oh she does sing a little bit Eric
doesn't she sing
[Music]
can you sing
oh I don't know
so we'll keep an eye on any more casting
news for the wicked movie uh it's been a
long time coming well this is
I believe uh
pulling a Christina riccially maybe she
might uh kill one of the other stars to
take their part I don't know I love
musical theaters I love musicals but for
some reason this entire time I kept
thinking even when I told you about
Michelle yo I was thinking into the
woods oh and now I'm like oh it's wicked
it's wicked
she's gonna play The Ram teacher yeah
that's what I think she will play at the
ram teacher yeah she'll play the the
teacher who gets her to do magic and
then eventually starts working for the
Wizards yeah
there's a female teacher and a male
teacher
Jeff Goldblum is going to be in there
of course for folks that don't know this
is one of the most successful Broadway
musicals of all time yeah uh there's
they're doing a tomb they're splitting
up into two films oh thank God there's a
wicked Cinematic Universe the first film
will be coming out in 2024 and I believe
the second one in 2025. and remember it
wasn't the classic song I'm a wicked
witch and I'm here to say well I love
casting spells in a major way
Alakazam and the Kazar these wicked
witches are so bizarre
the same song wait a second I have a
question don't Google wicked pictures by
the way okay all right that was your
question yeah
um
if Leah Michelle is gonna beat it
someone better record her lines for her
on tape
like just live today the Daily Mail
started posting a series of set photos
from the acolyte the upcoming Star Wars
series set in 132 BBY that's before the
Battle of Yavin at the end of the high
Republic look at that uh we didn't pull
all the picks and we don't spoil
everything but there's a Wookie in it
look at this with a top-notchy boy I
thought he was wearing a Lakers
the new starting
forwards used to wear clothes and then
they were like screw this where
yeah and now one photo we weren't able
to grab
um Daphne Keane yeah is cast in a series
and there was a photo release of her she
has cornrows and Daphne Keane the little
girl from Logan yes is a grown ass woman
it's like how does time passes way too
fast she was this tall and now she's
like a full-size adult now that's how I
feel about the last of us I did not know
that was the little girl from Game of
Thrones yeah I did not and I was like
that can't be I was like
no one grows up no one grows up there's
the headline people grow up uh next
headline Zoe Saldana Savage uh ghosts
you know when we were doing our Gamora
death uh I would give gamora's death
five yonders now it's going up every day
I think this might be here this might be
the end of Gamora as Zoe's aldana as
Gomorrah she uh
about an interview about if you remember
an Instagram post from last February
where she was holding the Guardians of
the Galaxy script uh for volume three
and she was in Gamora makeup uh in this
interview she said Marvel security made
her take the post down and she also said
quote I really enjoy working with
filmmakers that don't underestimate my
intelligence and know that I am an adult
I will be discreet it isn't as important
to me as as it is for him or her but I
don't let these scripts out of my sight
okay Zoe we're here well and she was
also complaining that like they don't
let them have the scripts for a long
time and sometimes it's on an iPad and
they take it away and to be fair she
sounded a little better when you read
the folks yeah in context she's like I
take myself sometimes too serious I'm
this very serious actress I want to be
able to study the lines and memorize
them and research them and literally
sometimes these Marvel actors they get
to look at it in a locked room on an
iPad and then they take the script away
from them you know the thing is that
sucks but weird fans like us I mean it
wouldn't be us we're not the ones that
are gonna break in we don't do that this
is Zoe Saldana and steal the freaking
thing that some people do so also like I
get her Point like oh they made me take
down my Instagram post but if they said
like hey please don't take any pictures
of the script ever it's like people who
go to the Grand Canyon and Lead over the
rails for for the gram like Zoe you
don't got to do it for the girls I guess
I'm just mad and I'm not mad I just
don't like her being like they're
they're coming from my intelligence it's
like it's not that it's just that fans
are sometimes willing to go for us to be
like I'm not gonna break the rules and
then you broke the rule and it's like
that's how they have to but I didn't
like that when I broke you really told
me not to Eric made me take down an
Instagram post once because I shared his
blood type okay that's weird uh we've
talked about so we saw Donna has been in
three franchises more long at least
three but like right Star Trek films
obviously the Guardians movies and like
she's appeared right she's in the
Pirates franchise Pirates was used in
one of those but then and then Avatar
right like that's 16 years apart this
woman has done so many big blockbuster
movies where she's against the Green
Screen she's a little over it we need to
come up with a term for the opposite of
a thirsty thespian like she's full
yeah and I think that's part of it she's
like I want to do this stage she wants
to it she wants to do Meryl Streep in
the wicked movie
go to UCB take an improv class teaching
him you know what come on the show maybe
hosting is your future
baby on a trailer like Jessica and I in
our 300 000 views uh Transformers Trail
watch that video if you haven't already
uh next headline folks Avatar is going
to be played on broadcast television For
the First Time ahead of the release it's
a way of water the first one yeah this
is the first time this has been on
television
broadcast television yeah uh so the
movie is 162 minutes if you don't
remember it's gonna be air on uh the ABC
Network on December 11th in a 210 minute
block that's three and a half hours uh
that's a lot a few commercial
interruptions uh and then it's also
gonna air on FX a couple times after
that so they're putting it on TV
ABC's got three and a half hours to give
up easily they've only got so many
episodes of Abbott Elementary but they
could rerun the season finale from last
year you know what I'm saying dog ABC
Family does The 25 Days of Christmas
right putting it on pause for this well
this is ABC oh okay
heart attack don't worry you're 25 Days
of Christmas they're gonna put little uh
Santa hats on the navi they're gonna say
I see you on Christmas they're gonna
plug their hair into Christmas trees
and then they light up like Christmas
lights that's how they have sex with
their hair
it's been a couple years since I've seen
Avatar do they have genitals and the
hair braids it's just in the hair but
not not in the groin
shut them pregnant yeah those are it
doesn't come out of the hair because I
know maybe it opens up like the creature
and shape of water you know what I'm
saying where it was the cone and it
comes up in like that so maybe similar
to what time you said earlier about
Googling don't Google
I want to know if they have nipples guys
just DM me directly I'll show you my
artwork uh next headline Google and
bathroom Rod the actor who plays ravona
rensslayer on the local series had some
interesting things to say about Loki
season 2 in an interview with E.T online
formerly the publication Entertainment
Tonight
okay she's had fans uh she said quote
fans in Loki
oh sorry I I wrote the song she said
that uh in Loki ravona is power of
powerful presence and that rinselayer
makes it out of the TVA which I'm really
excited about uh and this really got us
thinking about what's going on with
ravona in the show because the last we
saw her in the season finale she watched
that time door uh and this is before he
who remains as killed and when Loki
comes back to the TV she's obviously not
there but Mobius is there 115 is there
and their brains are different they
don't recognize Loki everything looks
different so I I take this to mean that
like whatever happened to them didn't
happen to her yeah her brain was not
white right yeah she hasn't been changed
out in the world with her full mind of
what yeah so like her and Loki are kind
of the only two people like that that we
know of right yeah and Sylvie I guess
yeah yeah because Sylvie wasn't there
either and I remember right before she
leaves she said she's going to find the
truth or going to find I forget what she
said she was going she's fine yeah but
she's looking for something so here's a
question for for you fine folks do you
is ravona Rensselaer going to be aligned
with Kang in all of this or do you think
she's out to to stop Kang since her
whole reality was shattered when she
learned the truth and that it was all
about those those weird three statues
she thought those were her she bought
into it behind the curtain no to be and
I when I say to be fair I mean okay
who's there
to be fair
um they so Kang died right and it
altered the timeline and that's where we
wake up and we see the new Statue of him
in the middle of the TVA right so would
that affect her as well like the
situation like everything resetting and
now they're like oh the TVA is fine it's
back to normal would that affect her I
don't think if she wasn't there in in
the TVA space in that timeline yeah
okay so she's back there being a public
school teacher I don't even know if
she's that I think she would be aligned
with Kang but only because I I want her
with gang eventually but I think it's
also that like now that the timeline has
changed maybe there was there that three
statue presence is no longer there it's
just Kang she's like oh I can align with
these yeah and this guy hates the other
guy that started the entire Trend so I'm
gonna go yeah that's interesting because
like even if she does feel a sense of
betrayal like I was misled this whole
time there was this guy behind those
three statues manipulating me but that
guy's gone yeah this is another version
of that guy so I'm not mad at this
version right
um I'll say this I'm Gaga for Google and
I uh no no no stay stay I think we're
missing the point
Strange bedfellows who are the two
people that can remember everything Loki
and ren Slayer they don't like each
other but guess what they just might
need each other oh well Loki might need
her to help
fixed she still knows the building
inside and out there's just some new
decorations guess what I will say the
posters up on your way some people some
people have pointed out the strength of
a Marvel series is often correlated with
the ship ability of it yeah you know
what I mean like the romantic thing at
its core or the Quasi romantic like
Trend obviously One Division had a great
one right between Wanda and vision
um what if and you know Loki and Sylvie
had like this weird kind of kissing
cousins kind of fun
they're cousins they're like the same
person
kept them from
lean to it whereas they could totally
totally lean into uh
uh Slayer and low they could be straight
up getting it on red low you can get it
almost over
red Smokey's a good name hashtag runs
Loki is this the hashtag sign revoki uh
revoking
it's a throuple oh it's a throttle
we did have GSU Eagle 117 sending a
Super Chat saying hey everyone are you
guys gonna be watching the game awards
right after uh the game awards are
tonight uh the video games biggest night
uh but we are watching for one thing yes
and that's that Jedi Survivor trailer
trailer that's coming out the sequel to
Jedi Fallen order but who uh we're very
excited to see that I think that
actually drops at 4 30 Pacific it's
gonna drop right before the game awards
very that's
an hour from now it's coming up real
quick but I think they were also
supposed to have like gameplay footage
of that game at the game awards there
was also a tweet that this is going to
be like the shortest game of wards in a
very long time
but the fortnite
chapter I can't remember what number
just dropped the trailer for it so maybe
they're wearing that and I'll be doing
this dance we are expecting some big
game stuff next year there's a lot of
big games that overlap with the the new
rock stars uh Universe right some kind
of comixy games you want that trailer
broken down you tweet at us maybe your
boy goes back to the gaming world and
breaks down Jedi Survivor for you baby
maybe I do that for you maybe I'm the
king of games on this channel now
we're gonna have to fly your nephew out
here so he can beat the game probably
yeah yeah you should oh my nephew James
is gonna have to come out here and show
me how to beat the puzzles
it's Tommy in the video but these tiny
hands through his shirts
we should all fly out our nephews to
help us play these games
Julius would be so good yeah yeah James
and Julius they should have their own
show JJ the JJ and he'll just be me you
but you guys get the point we'll boss
him around uh Super Chat from here for
the cookies saying in to the tune of
Silent Night to
be fair okay uh and Quentin also sent in
a Super Chat
and fly ninja 808 was set in a Super
Chat when we're talking about all the DC
stuff so it all made sense because they
don't they don't want to confirm
anything in the Snyder versus Canon
anymore and they are also hoping to see
Mamoa as
loboa I say that in my room and that's
what I meant when I was talking about
the DC stuff I was like yeah it seems
like when you're trying to start fresh
and move on it's like the Snyder verse
was a big portion of that and so you
gotta gotta cut ties yeah and the last
thing
one thing I forget to mention in that
discussion too right like we're assuming
all these signature actors are done with
these franchises is they won't want them
back there's a case to be made for like
hems like how uh Chris Hemsworth pivoted
from uh Thor the Dark World to Thor
Ragnarok that was almost like a reboot
of that yeah totally it was what if they
did the same thing with Henry Cavill
right what if we got Henry Cavill
Superman but in a totally different
environment this Flash movie could
really just reset things in a good way
and I I'm all for you know what Marvel
has done is very impressive I think a
lot of Studios have tried to copy that
formula and to varying degrees of
success yeah I'm fine with the world of
comic stories that are just I can put
wrap my head around the idea that when
Batman takes off his mask is a different
face and but you know the idea of just
these characters and telling these
stories when we read comic books the art
changes all the time the power sets
change don't we want to live in a world
where every other year we get a Batman
movie and a Superman movie I think yes
please honestly okay I'm never gonna be
over Batman I don't know why I just
can't yeah I would love it all the time
I love one every year
um and I guess it comes
I guess it comes down also to the fact
like I would be okay with them kind of
doing a reboot but it's the same people
yeah it's just going to rely on the
acting yeah and if the acting's not
there for your role in the reboot take
me to camera for him
I'm not having it there it is you heard
it exactly exercises you're a Batman and
I'm the Riddler real quick we gotta we
got a last second Super Chat uh from
Austin long this is my favorite panel of
rock stars
he's heading on vacation to South
Carolina tomorrow
it's 5 a.m in the British Chicago
airport yeah thank you O'Hare or Midway
because there's a big difference big
difference yeah oh here they got you
walking miles to get through those go
buy gardettos get yourself some nice
popcorn yeah
cheddar caramel mix baby gross yeah
go to the uh Hudson News and get a
gardetto go to the hunt two news and get
a Playboy come on can you get flavor at
the airport I don't know
[Music]
if you pull that out and and Coach
it's November the plane's going down
I gotta get to the cartoon
I can't die before I see this
coach I'd be so bad but can you close
that no no so today do they have a print
point no they stopped doing print uh
they're online only how do you know so
much they did stop they did stop doing
nudity for a little while but they've
gone back oh they're back how about
Hustler they make that now uh hustle
does whatever they want 78 year old
Hustlers guys P.O box six nine six nine
I'm sure you can get like a Victoria's
Secret catalog oh yeah so I have plenty
of those uh hey we thank you so much for
watching everybody
[Music]
uh come back tomorrow for our special
holiday episode we've got some other fun
stuff planned there'll be some probably
some special guests you might recognize
me and maybe a big man with a beard
doing some stuff that's unpredictable
both
who's to say uh like And subscribe if
you haven't already
um hey check out new rockstars merch.com
if you're looking for holiday gifts for
your friends and family Jessica's
rocking one of our special hoodies right
now it's a very comfortable stylish
hoodie
otherwise have a great uh evening
afternoon morning whatever time it is
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]